So welcome to week three of uh uh 203.
So as per our usual m uh road map uh
today we are today and tomorrow we'll be
still in the open loop quadrant of our
of our road map. Specifically last week
we so we introduced the general concept
of openloop control uh which is to be
kind of uh compared to with closed loop
control which we will be the topic of of
next week and specifically in open loop
control we kind of highlighted the fact
that we are interested in a control uh
kind of an optimal control signal or
trajectory uh which is only a signal of
the initial time t. So we are looking
for an optimal control trajectory u of t
and specifically uh kind of within these
class of methods we uh discussed that
there are two macro kind of
subcategories indirect methods and
direct methods. Last week we introduced
indirect method which uh loosely
speaking uh kind of relate with first of
all deriving optimality conditions for
the infinite dimensional optimal control
problem and solving for those uh if you
wish kind of the analog we usually
recalled was the one from finite
dimensional optimization whereby kind of
the optimality conditions were akin to
the gradient of f equal to zero
conditions. Uh of course in finite
dimensional case uh those kind of those
optimality conditions so gradient equal
to zero uh bo down to a system of
algebraic equations in the case of
infinite dimensional optimization which
is the one you're interested in for
optimal control these optimality
condition boils down to differential
equations uh but the highle picture is
is the same and so today we'll be
finishing our discussion on indirect
methods and then on Wednesday we'll be
looking at uh direct methods
And specifically for today we will start
by extending the optimality conditions
which we introduced last time uh which
assume that we had unbounded controls.
And so today we will be extending those
optimality conditions specifically for
the case of bounded controls which is a
very common kind of constraint to have
in practice when you're dealing with
with optimal control problems. And we
will see how this will lead towards the
kind of celebrated Pontraan uh minimum
principle.
uh we'll then look at uh various
different examples specifically we'll be
looking at some kind of archetype
optimal control problems first of all to
see how we can use these uh optimality
conditions in practice and get
familiarity with that uh but also from
the perspective of inspecting the kind
of control profile that we get out of
these optimality conditions
and then we'll conclude this part by
looking at computational methods so we
have been describing indirect methods
over and over as optimize then
discretise uh methods. Again, in
comparison to the direct approaches
which are uh discretized then optimize
methods uh and specifically the
optimized part entailed with deriving
the optimality conditions and solving
for those differential equations and the
discretized part related with feeding
those differential equations to a
numerical solver which is also what
we'll be looking at with the
computational methods.
Okay, so just as a reminder, so last
time we concluded by uh looking at this
optimal control problem where we had
assume that we had unbounded controls.
So again to to to recap the notation
here, we assume that we have a system
described by the following dynamics. Uh
and the goal is to find an admissible
control U star which causes the system
to follow an admissible trajectory XAR
that minimizes the given cost functional
which is a combination of a terminal
cost H and a kind of stage cost G that
is integrated over time.
And uh indeed we assumed uh uh that this
both the states and the control regions
uh were unbounded.
And this led into defining the following
optimal necessary and optimality
conditions which at a high level
entailed first of all defining the
Hamiltonian which if you want acted as
the analog of the lrangen function in
finite dimensional case where we
basically where the Hamiltonian is
defined as the stage cost plus a term
which represents our uh dynamics f uh
times a vector of co or a function of
costates p of
uh which uh again represents the analog
of the lranjen multipliers
and uh in finite dimensional
optimization the lranian multipliers
were uh denoted as lambda. Here we
denote these cost states as p uh which
are indeed a function of time and
they're called cost states because there
is one costate variable or function for
every state uh function.
And so given that we defined the
Hamiltonian we saw how the optimality
conditions boil down to defining the set
of differential equations. Uh the first
one representing trivally our dynamics.
So if we take the partial derivative of
our Hamiltonian with respect to the
co-state variable p we get our dynamics.
So x dot equals f. The second two set of
equations are uh less intuitive, but we
saw how the second one essentially bo
down to uh uh p dot equals the minus the
partial derivative of the Hamiltonian
with respect to x. And then we saw how
the third set of algebraic equations uh
represented a stationary condition on of
the control with respect to the
Hamiltonian.
And and so uh essentially that the
derivative of the Hamiltonian with
respect to u needs to be equal to zero.
And we saw how in practice this boil
down very mechanically towards usually
using this last set of algebraic
equations to express u as a function of
x and p. We can then do the appropriate
substitutions in the differential
equations which we can then solve. To
solve these differential equations, we
saw how this generated kind of boil down
into having to pinpoint a number of
constants of integration and we saw how
we could use boundary conditions to
pinpoint those uh constants of
integration.
Usually uh the initial uh boundary
conditions are given. So we know the
state at time zero and we know what the
time zero is. Um but the boundary
conditions at the final time depend a
bit on the scenario that we're looking
at. And so we saw how we could use this
kind of master uh boundary condition
depending on whether the final time or
final state is free or fixed. For
example um if the final state is fixed
it means that there are no admissible
variations delta xf we can do. And so
all of this term has to goes to zero.
And so we're left with this other part
of the boundary condition and vice
versa.
Any any questions on until this as a as
a general recap of where we are?
Okay.
And indeed so as I mentioned before so
far we have assumed uh that both the
admissible controls and states um are
not constrained by any boundaries. But
in in reality kind of states and control
constraints are actually extremely
common in practice. Um so for example
kind of a classical control constraints
might uh model that we have some limits
in our actuation. So again we cannot
impose like a thrust that is infinitely
large. Um and uh also state constraints
might be quite common. For example uh
just to give you an idea kind of a
classical state constraint might
represent obstacle avoidance. So where
we want to avoid some kind of obstacle
in the in the physical space.
Now for the purpose of this class we'll
focus on uh including the case of bounds
on the controls and we will not discuss
the case where we include the bounds or
constraints on the states. uh first of
all because it the kind of mechanics
become substantially more more complex
and also because in practice um indirect
methods are not really the tool of
choice to handle uh constraints on
states. So what people usually do would
maybe cast the problem as a motion
planning problem where you're kind of
abstracting away from the dynamics or at
least simplifying the dynamics and more
geometrically solving the trajectory
optimization problem and then you're
using those insights that you get from
these more abstract uh solutions to
inform your indirect methods. So long
story short, but what we're saying here
is that we want to expand our analysis
and we're going to focus on the bounds
on the controls.
Yes,
>> the example from last lecture where we
were using the
conditional controls you had in the
previous slide and then we had a like
[clears throat] a talent some expression
in terms of a you were saying that um
here
was that actually when we solved that
problem did we actually find an optimal
control or or is it what you're saying
that you knew it couldn't be anything
therefore TF could be anything
>> and now we're going to introduce What
setting are you referring to?
>> In previous lecture, we did we did an
example. We found that T final.
>> Mhm.
>> It's in terms of alpha.
>> Yes.
>> Did that correspond to some particular
optimum control or
>> is that what you're saying that it was
unconstrained? So the control could be
anything and therefore the T final could
be anything.
>> No. So in that case we actually solved
the problem completely. So in this slide
I only highlighted the final time TF
which was like a complex thing like over
1,800 or something like that. Um but of
course once we solve the for the
necessary optimality condition so once
we solve the differential equations we
have everything. So we have X we have P
and usually the controls are a function
of X and P and so by just substituting
those X and P that we get by solving the
differential equations we would get our
the shape of our control.
So here what I mean by bounds on
controls is that we would have something
like uh the absolute value of u needs to
be smaller or equal than one
>> something like that.
Does this clarify? And it's possible
that because we didn't have the
constraint in the other problem that
force them given alpha and b it could
result in an optimal control that
violates a constraint.
>> Yes, of course. Then we were not
imposing this constraint. So we are not
really sure about the you know if we're
respecting any any kind of constraint
like this. Yeah. But it will it'll be
clear in in a couple of slides because
we'll be making some some concrete
examples.
Okay.
So now before kind of showing you how
the optimality conditions will change, I
just want to give you a small uh kind of
insight into why uh the bounds of
control on the controls kind of
complicate the analysis. And the way
we'll kind of build this intuition is by
as usual referring to the finite
dimensional uh case. And so
recall from our u discussions on finite
dimensional optimization where in order
to derive the optimality conditions of
the gradient of f needs to be equal to
zero. We started by
looking at the increment of our function
with respect to some uh displacement
delta x. And we saw how this could be
well approximated by
our function f ofx plus the gradient of
f transpose delta x or we call this the
differential
plus some high order terms.
Right? So and essentially by just
bringing the f ofx on the other side of
the of the equation what we get is that
the increment of our function
uh is well approximated for small delta
x's by the by our differential. So the
linear part of our approximation of our
tailor expansion
and we know that for a point x to be a
candidate local minimum what it means is
that for any displacement delta x that I
make this increment has to be greater or
equal than zero. Right? So wherever I
move I essentially I'm increasing the
value of my function.
Now in the unconstrained case uh we were
able to translate this expression so
that specifically that the differential
has to be greater or equal than zero uh
to the fact that in order for this to be
greater equal than zero since I can take
any possible uh displacement delta x
both in the positive and in the negative
direction the only way for this to be
both greater than equal zero or less or
equal than zero is for the gradient of f
to be
equal to zero. Right? So this is
essentially what we said uh a couple
weeks back.
Now visually
what this means is that
if we have a function
that looks something like this
and assuming I'm not considering the
boundary points of this function the
gradient of f equal to zero essentially
gives us a mechanism to uh to isolate
candidates for for local minimums right
where specifically in this case one is a
local minimum and two here are local
maximum but still they're candidates
right according to our optimality
conditions.
Now what happens if we do consider the
boundaries here?
So is this a local minima?
I see some nodings. Uh can can you say
why this is a local minimum?
>> Yes. Because if you move anywhere on
that curve that's still you know within
your boundaries you're always
>> exactly correct. So in this case
remember that here we're defining
minimums are as uh whatever movement
admissible delta x I take I'm in
increasing the value of my function. In
this case the only displacements I can
take are ones on the positive direction
on the right. And so for all of these
displacements the value of my function
is is greater. Right? So this is indeed
local minimum. Same thing for this other
point here. Of course, kind of mirrored
where the only displacements that I can
take are in the negative direction.
[snorts] So you see that when I'm
considering these boundaries kind of the
uh condition that the grad of f is equal
to zero doesn't really cut it anymore,
right?
And so going back to this math kind of
what we know in the bounded case is that
this has to hold, right? But we're not
able to do the um kind of the point that
these displacements can be both in the
positive or negative direction but they
depend on the boundary. And so the uh
optimality condition in this case is
that the differential has to be greater
or equal than zero. Now this complicates
kind of a series of other discussions
when we actually want to make this
actionable but this is the kind of
difference that it makes in the finite
dimensional case.
In the infinite dimensional case when we
move to optimizing to calculus of
variation the exact same intuition
applies and specifically remember that
um we derived the optimality conditions
uh again starting from the uh variation
of our cost functional J which we
denoted as uh delta J.
uh and in order for a candidate you
start to be a minimum uh or a relative
minimum uh we we want that this
increment is greater than zero right so
exactly as in the finite dimensional
case
now we what we did uh last week is that
we um
approximated this increment through its
uh linear term or the variation delta j
uh plus some higher order terms And then
we use the fact that these deltaU's
could be arbitrary to derive the
fundamental theorem of calculus of
variation that is that delta j so the
variation delta j needed to be equal to
zero.
Right? So I I I trust that you're kind
of seeing the analog here.
Now when we talk about kind of let's
open a small parenthesis when we talk
about variations in calculus of
variation. So what does deltau look
like? because a displacement in delta x
kind of intuitively makes sense. But
here we're talking about uh functions,
right? So delta u itself is a function.
So if you want visually
um
say that uh we have a function over time
and that we have uh some kind of
uh bound in our controls which we denote
as u bar meaning that our controls
cannot go above this this bound. Um our
control u of t might look something like
this where for some time we are in the
admissible region. Uh then we are still
admissible but at the boundary and there
perhaps we could go down right. So this
could be a potential uh control function
ut. So a displacement delta ut in this
case is a function itself right. So it
could be any variation that I do to my
function ut. Now in this part of the
region where I'm not at the boundary the
variations that I can take could be both
deltaU but also negative deltaU right so
uh variations is both directions are
admissible
but in the case where I'm uh where my
control lies at the boundary then here I
can only take the uh variation in only
on kind of one-sided if that makes sense
and so what this boils down to and in
general whenever I'm trying to uh
optimize some kind of uh
could be final time given some
constraints it is very common that you
at for some portion of my control
profile I will be at the boundary at
some point and it turns out that when if
my optimal if the optimal control lies
on a boundary then the necessary
conditions similarly to how it did in
the finite dimensional
essentially boils down that the uh
variation delta J uh has to be greater
or equal than than zero.
Any any questions on how we we got to uh
to this update to our conditions?
>> Yes. Sorry if you mentioned it before,
but on that lower plot that you have
there, what was the connection to that
expression to the you could only vary in
one direction?
>> Uh, sorry question. So here,
>> yeah, I think I'm just I'm confused how
that would be a situation where you
could only I think you said something
like vary in one direction.
>> Yes. No, it's a good question. So uh
remember that uh a lot of the
uh kind of logic that we're following
when we're doing those statements over
there was that the admissible variations
were arbitrary right and so this allowed
us to essentially derive that the
variation of J so delta J has to be
equal to zero in the fundamental theorem
of calculus of variation so here I was
trying to kind of visualize what does it
mean for first of all to be a variation
in the space of functions but then also
what does it mean for a variation to be
bounded so that it's not uh arbitrary
right so in this space of my control
function here my variations are actually
arbitrary so admissible variations are
arbitrary because I could go in both
directions here when I'm my control is
at a boundary I cannot displace my
function in in the positive direction
here right because I would violate my my
band yeah and so the only thing that I
meant here is that the boundaries
essentially
break the uh assumption that my
variations are admiss that any variation
is admissible and so this does not allow
us to make the statement that the delta
j is equal to zero. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
Okay.
Now this of course then you can imagine
that uh the consequences of this is on
our optimality conditions are that we
have to strengthen our condition on the
control u and specifically these are the
updated conditions uh which are referred
to as the pontraan's minimum principle
uh where we are as you as it is I
highlighted here on the slide we're
essenting essentially updating and
strengthening the condition on the
stationerity of our control U. [snorts]
So everything stays exactly the same as
the conditions that we saw before with
the addition that or kind of
modification that before the optimal
control U had to be a stationary point
of the Hamiltonian. So the gradient of H
with respect to U had to be equal to
zero.
Now we want the optimal control U to be
a global minimizer of the Hamiltonian.
So essentially the Hamiltonian evaluated
at the optimal candidate u star is uh
smaller or equal than the Hamiltonian
evaluated at any other u of t admissible
control u.
Of course there is a jump from the fact
that the variation has to be greater or
equal than zero towards the updated
optimality conditions. Um
but uh kind of the bottom line here is
again we want to be kind of pragmatic
and functional and uh when we introduce
bounds on our controls it boils down to
towards updating and strengthening some
of our optimality conditions which in
this case entails uh having to minimize
the Hamiltonian rather than only being a
stationary point.
any any questions here? Again,
mechanically, we kind of provided some
insight into what is more complex the
moment we consider bounds on controls.
Um, and then we stated the updated
optimality conditions.
Okay, so
let's now make an example to kind of
operationalize uh these updated
optimality conditions.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay. And so specifically here we're
looking at uh the following uh system
which is a second order uh system with
kind of linear dynamics.
Uh and where we want to optimize the
cost functional that is represented as a
kind of squared cost functional a
quadratic cost functional. Um we are
assuming that the final time is fixed
and the final stage is free. But note
that here now we are introducing this
bound on the controls specifically that
the absolute value has to be uh less or
equal than than one [snorts] when we are
so these types of problems that is when
we are trying to minimize the uh squared
of our controls uh so a quadratic cost
are also known as minimum energy uh
problems. Yes,
>> definition from the previous slide. What
does it mean to say that you're you know
the inequality of age of all the stuff
stars?
>> What does it mean for you not to be
optimal like X and P just will be like
how can you have a nonoptimal U but then
an optimal X optimal U. So in general
remember that these are a set of
conditions for any candidate triplet of
states controls and co-ates.
Now the first two are differential
equations. Here we are basically
strengthening the condition the
algebraic conditions which essentially
entail that the controls the candidate
control u had to be a stationary point
for the Hamiltonian given x and p and in
this we are basically strengthening that
condition whereby you should basically
see that we're trying to minimize this
function only as a function of u right
so given some x and ps we are finding
the global minimum with respect to u of
Yeah, if you want there you could also
interpret it as um
U star needs to be the
uh argument of H
uh
of XAR U star.
Right? So this is basically saying that
for any candidate U star T, it has to be
a global minimizer for any other U of T
that I could replace it with.
[clears throat]
>> We're now highlighting that this is a
global minimum. Was it not the global
minimum before?
>> Uh before we only needed that you had to
be a stationary one of the Hamiltonian.
We only enforced that the derivative the
partial derivative of the Hamiltonian
with respect to u had to be equal to
zero. Now we're actually enforcing uh
that for kind of the strengthened
condition you not only has to be a
stationary point but it has to be a
global minimum.
Maybe one so I know that we kind of took
a sort of kind of a big jump in defining
this strength and condition but maybe
one way in which you could relate this
condition to the one we had previously
that is how to relate the global
minimization of the hamiltonian with
respect to u and the stationary uh point
condition is that so we this condition
is essentially strengthened because we
are introducing bounds on controls
Right? Now assume that we are kind of
loosening these bounds on the controls
so much. So visually if you remember
here we had this kind of U bar which
represented our bound. We are increasing
it so much that it's not an issue
anymore for our for our problem.
If we are increasing it so much that
it's not anymore an issue for our
problem then any kind of global minimum
of our Hamiltonian is also a stationary
point. Right? So there is a link here in
the sense that if our control bounds are
so loose that they're not an issue
anymore, then a necessary condition for
control u to be uh global minimum of h
is it to be st um a stationary point.
[clears throat]
>> No, this is just like a mental exercise
just to show some kind of link between
this formulation and the one we had
previously.
Did this confuse you even more?
[laughter]
>> Okay.
Again, bottom line here is that we want
to define these optimality conditions.
Uh now we are compared to the one where
we had previously uh we are introducing
some bound on the controls. These bound
of the controls bolt down to having to
strengthen this third algebraic uh kind
of condition. Before it was just
enforcing that U had to be a stationary
point of the Hamiltonian. Now we want
use to be a global minimizer of the
Hamiltonian.
>> Yes.
>> We would like if there are a condition
we would use to find the optimal control
inputs and then plug those into the
differential equations for X and P. But
I'm having trouble understanding how we
would optimize over like we would
optimize over the Hamiltonian like as if
we already knew the optimal state and
like Xar and P star because I assume
that the like X and the control inputs
and the states are coupled.
>> Yeah, it's a it's a question and it'll
be clear I think one slide from now
because we're exactly solving a problem
and so you'll see how we do it. Uh the
bottom line is that uh obviously this is
complicating things because before it
was just enforcing an algebraic equation
where we would express x as a function
function of uh u as a function of x and
p and then doing the substitution. Now
we will be solving this optim we'll
basically have to solve an optimization
problem and derive a solution of u as a
function of x and p and then doing the
substitution again. So mechanically it
doesn't change much. It's just more
complex because before it was enforcing
an an algebraic equation. Now it's
solving an an optimization problem.
Yeah.
Okay. So
indeed we want to approach this minimum
energy uh problem where now we have some
uh bounds on the controls
and specifically again we want to be as
usual we want to be uh methodical. So we
define the Hamiltonian
as 12
x1 squared plus u ^2 and here I'm
omitting uh dependency on time just to
to save something
plus the uh cost state uh times our
dynamics function f
p1 p2 2
transpose x2
- x2 + u
which we can write as 12
x1 2 + u ^2 + p1
x2
minus
p2 x2 2
plus P2 U.
Okay,
so this is just our Hamiltonian. Now we
want to enforce our third condition that
is that U has to be a global minimizer
of the Hamiltonian. So the new condition
that we just uh strengthened.
So we basically want to solve this
problem here, right? So u star has to be
a global minimizer of the Hamiltonian.
Now if this is the Hamiltonian, the only
terms that depend on use are these two
here. And so this problem essentially
boils down to minimizing
over u 12 u ^2 + p2 u.
Is the marker
strong [snorts] enough this week? Not
really.
All right, let's try let's try this
other one.
I love the variance of the of this.
Okay. Yes.
Okay.
All right. So, but can you can you read
this this one here?
Anybody that cannot read it? Okay.
All right. So, uh notice that this is a
quadratic function. So, in order to
minimize it, we can just set the
gradient of this equal to zero.
Right? So, we can just set the gradient
with respect to u of this thing here. So
of 12 u ^2 + p2 u equal to zero
which essentially means that
u + p2
has to be equal to zero and so u
is equal to minus p2.
Right? So now to answer to your question
you see here we solved an optimization
problem. The output of this optimization
problem is still expressing u as a
function of only p in this case but in
general it could be a function of x and
okay now uh we have to analyze so we
have u is has some bounds right so we
have some bounds on the values of you
and so we need to basically look at
different kind of case by case uh
studies
so
specifically we will be looking at three
cases
where our bounds are that u has to be uh
between minus1 and one. And so we'll be
looking at the case where
this global minimizer minus p2 is
smaller than -1.
We'll be looking at minus P2
being between minus1 and one or the fact
that minus P2 is greater than one.
Right? We'll be looking at these three
cases because ideally the optimal
control will be negative P2. But there
are some bounds on you that we have to
uh respect.
Uh visually if you want to
have a sense of what is happening this
is a quadratic function. So something
that looks like this. The minimum is at
negative P2.
And now we'll be analyzing different
cases depending on where P minus P2
falls. So the most obvious one is if if
minus P2 is feasible. So it falls
between negative 1 and one. So say
something like this.
Then the optimal U would just be minus
P2. Right?
[snorts] Now, now say that negative P2
is smaller than uh minus one. So we are
in a situation where
this is negative. Say that one one is
here. What is the what would be the
optimum in this case? the optimal U in
this case,
right? So this is the function we want
to minimize which is our Hamiltonian.
Uh we can only choose within
minus one and one. So in this case where
where would the minimum be? Yes.
>> Yeah. Exactly.
So in this case the minimum would be
minus one. And you can imagine kind of a
a similar argument if uh negative p2 is
greater than one. So the interval now
sits on the left of negative p2 and the
maxi the minimum here would be one.
[snorts] Right? So essentially now we
have solved the third and strengthen
condition. So we found the uh global
minimum of uh the Hamiltonian with
respect to u. Uh and now we basically
have what we need right because now we
have an expression of u as a function of
uh x and p in this case only the coates
p uh which we can substitute in the
differential equations above uh feed
them into a solver and get the solution
out. Um,
interestingly enough, uh, and this is I
think one of the kind of strong points
of indirect methods is that regardless
of the solution, so the what the exact
control is, we have basically pinpointed
the structure of how our control looks
like, right? So now let's plot
um our control
U as a function of P2.
What we have now is that our control in
between minus1 and one. So if P2 is
between minus1 and one, it'll basically
look something like this.
On the other hand,
uh when it is below negative one, it
will be saturating at one and it when it
is above one, it will be saturating at
at minus one. Right?
So our control profile is essentially uh
linear and saturating after some point.
Now, of course, in the moment where we
didn't have those bounds, our optimal
control would just be the linear part,
right?
Okay. Any any questions on this?
Yeah,
>> I understand this is like the the third
condition of the contract
check. What about the other two?
>> Yes, it's a it's a good question. So
basically now here we express u as a
function of x and p. Uh the kind of the
mechanics of this go that then we have
we take this expression we substituted
in the other two uh differential
equation uh conditions and we get some
differential equations which we then
solve either analytically as we did last
week or as we will see today through
numerical solvers.
>> So this is like
>> yes. Yes. So here we basically stopped
halfway there. So we just derived the
profile of U. So we just strengthened
condition. If you had to go kind of all
the way through, you would substitute
this in the other differential equations
and solve those differential equations.
Here we just stopped here. But just but
already said that already at this point
we can basically inspect the structure
of our control because whenever we will
solve those differential equations we
will get X's and P's and those X's and
P's in this case only P will allow us to
pinpoint our actual control which
regardless of the value of P will look
like something like this.
How do we use
>> uh those will be used to pinpoint the
those will be boundary conditions which
we use to pinpoint the constants of
integration in our differential
equations.
>> Yes.
>> Um so like for the example graph that
you drew there to kind of explain how
you found conditions what would like is
the x like what axis represents like
which one is you and which one or am I
just misunderstand?
>> Yeah. So this would be U and this would
be kind of the Hamiltonian as a function
of U.
>> Does it make sense?
>> Okay. Any any other questions in this?
We will see three more examples. So now
we're we're kind of we'll go through a
few of these of these cases.
Okay. And so indeed so exactly what we
get is is this kind of control, right?
So essentially what we derived here on
the on the SL on the whiteboard.
[snorts]
So be as a kind of as a caveat uh kind
of you know pontragan and and colleagues
derived some additional necessary
conditions depending on kind of the
exact structure of the problem. These
are not too relevant for us for the
purposes of this class. But I just
wanted to to mention that there are some
additional uh optimality conditions that
were derived. Uh specifically uh if the
final time is fixed and the Hamiltonian
does not depend on uh explicitly on
time. Uh
then it you know the the alternative
condition is that the Hamiltonian it has
to be uh constant for all times between
t0 and tf. And on the other hand, if the
final time and the Hamiltonian is free
and the Hamiltonian does not depend
explicitly on time, then the Hamiltonian
has to be equal to zero for all uh times
between T0 and TF. Uh now again do not
read too much into this. This is just I
wanted to use this as an example to
mention that there have been developed
additional optimality conditions which
at the end of the day are useful to
pinpoint even f further the structure of
your solution. So uh there are a number
of optimality conditions which have been
uh developed and these are additional
ones compared to the ones that we showed
before and if your problem falls within
these buckets then they're the more
optimality conditions you have the
better because you can characterize even
further what your uh optimal solution
looks like.
Okay. So what we'll be doing now is that
we'll be looking at three archetypes
essentially of optimal control problems.
Specifically, we'll be looking at uh
minimum time problems. So, get to your
goal as fast as possible. Uh we'll be
looking at minimum fuel problems uh
where the cost will be to minimize the
absolute value of uh the control effort.
Again, you could see this at the analog
of minimizing uh thrusts in if you're
looking at like aerospace applications.
And then we'll be looking at minimum
energy uh problems.
And so starting from um minimum time
problems uh we'll be looking at the case
where indeed we have some bounds on the
controls. So the control u is has to be
between some lower bound mi uh minus and
some upper bound mi plus
uh and we want to drive a controlin
system. So for these examples, we will
always be assuming the exact same system
which is a control a fine system in the
sense that it linearly depends on the
control UT.
Uh but this may potentially depend
nonlinearly on the state X and this is
because the A and B might be nonlinear
in X. But this still so it is fairly
general um kind of dynamical system and
formulation but it does simplify
slightly things because it is linear in
the controls
and again the purpose of minimum time
problems is to get to a goal as fast as
possible. In this case, we want to start
from an arbitrary state x0 and we want
to reach the origin in and the way we
encode this minimum time kind of the
minimization of time in terms of a
functional is that we want to minimize j
which is just the integral between t0
and tf of one. So we're just summing
time essentially. Yes.
>> Here is it like a time index or is it
like a different possible control? Uh we
are assuming that u here could be kind
of multivariate and so we have m control
variables.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yes. So imagine maybe you can
accelerate in different directions and
for each of those dimensions you have
some limits.
Okay. So
let's apply what we know to to solve
this uh this problem.
Okay,
so uh as usual we want to start from our
uh from defining the Hamiltonian, right?
So the Hamiltonian for us entails the
stage cost G, which for us is just one
plus the cost uh uh times our uh
dynamics, right? And so in this case it
will be P transpose A +
B.
[snorts] Now just as as a notation here
we will we will express B the matrix B
as in in in terms of its uh columns.
So
we can just rewrite B in this way
[snorts]
which essentially means that this is
equal to uh 1 + P transpose
A
plus the sum that goes from I to M of E
I UI and this is because then this
product here essentially entails uh
becomes the uh the linear combination of
its columns essentially.
Okay.
And we can rewrite this as 1 + panspose
a plus the summation that goes from 1 to
m of p transpose bi
ui. [snorts]
Right? Okay. So here we just wrote our
hamiltonian. Now as we did before we
want to uh start from the third or
optimality conditions which in this case
and according to the uh pontagan's
minimum principle it means that we want
to find you that is the global minimizer
of the Hamiltonian.
So as usual u star will be the minimum
with respect to u of the hamiltonian
which again out of these three terms
only the last one depends on you. And so
this essentially means that we want to
minimize u
um of this summation between and m of
the that term over there. So prpose bi
ui.
Now the controls are something that we
pick and these are independent according
to our problem formulation across uh m
right. And so minimizing the summation
is essentially equivalent to minimizing
the individual summation terms for all
i's that go from one to m.
And so this basically maps to minimizing
over ui of p transpose bi ui for all i's
that go from one to one.
Okay. Now does this make sense?
Yes. Now how do we uh minimize this?
Right. So again I think it's good to
consider different cases. So
specifically
our optimal control u star will depend
on whether panspose bi is positive
or whether prpose uh bi is negative.
Right? So if prpose di is positive uh
what is the minimizer u in this case?
>> [snorts]
>> Right? So we want to minimize this term
over here as a function of u. This will
depend on what this term in front of you
is. And so if this term is positive and
u has to be between mi minus and mi plus
uh how would you pick u in this case?
>> Yeah. Correct. Exactly.
So
m I minus right
and of course kind of by mirroring in
case p transpose bi is negative what is
u here it will be the uh the
upper bound right so mi plus
now
are we missing something here
>> yeah exactly and
The point here is that for prposebi
if for optimal controls for which
prposebi is or optimal triplets so
optimal x u and p for which prpose bis
is equal to zero the optimality
conditions do not give us any
characterization of any information
about what the uh optimal control looks
like. This is a kind of a condition that
is referred to as
singular
arcs
or singular conditions which essentially
says that the optimality conditions for
some uh kind of characteristics of our
triplet do not give us any information
about the optimal control u. Now, for
the purposes of this class, we won't be
dealing with singular arcs. And so, you
this is not a problem that should uh
bother you too much. uh but I just
wanted to kind of use this example as um
indeed an example of the kind of
problems that could emerge whereby in
this case there could be the situation
where uh my optimal is actually lies in
a situation where for some portion of my
time panspose bi is equal to zero and so
I would not know how to characterize my
controls. Now there could be some much
more sophisticated math in order to
pinpoint the charact the behavior of my
controls. In this case it is easier for
linear systems. It becomes much a
problem depending situ um kind of
solution in the moment where you're
looking at nonlinear systems. U but I I
think it's just important for you to
know that there might be situations
where uh where this these problems
emerge. And in a way this is actually
where most of the brain power when you
try to use indirect methods goes into is
tackling these uh kind of illonditioned
uh situations for us. Uh we you know
assuming that the optimal uh for our
optimal control problem. So the optimal
triplet x p and u does not fall into the
singular r conditions. We basically have
determined that our control has this
form here which is also known as a bang
bang uh control and this is because
essentially the control has a profile
that uh either accelerates uh kind of at
max velocity or breaks uh at its maximum
and if you think about what we're doing
here uh that is minimizing final time it
kind of makes sense right so we have
some linear system or control of fine
system we want to minimize time and So
we're not messing around, right? We
either go for full throttle or we break
at our maximum speed.
>> Yes.
>> Is equal to zero. Does that not
necessarily mean that it's
uncontrollable in that state?
>> It means that the optimality conditions
do not give us a characterization of how
the control looks like. So remember all
of these are optimality conditions that
allow us to pinpoint candidates for
optimality. And so this means that in
those situations these optimality
conditions do not give us information on
what an optimal looks like. Yeah.
Yes.
>> What is singular arcs like what types of
problems these are unique to?
>> Uh they're not unique to specific
problems but singular arc or singular
condition refers to those situations uh
for which we're the optimality
conditions are not able to characterize
uh the control essentially.
to the uh application of the pontragon.
>> Yes. Yes. So if you're applying the
pontraan minimum principle that is the
optimality conditions for optimal
control problems you might end up in
situations like these where we like at
face value we don't have enough
information to characterize what the
control look like.
Um, [snorts]
sorry we've [clears throat] said this
already, but I'm just confused. Did you
get that the controller is a bang bang
controller from
the panel over here or like the promo
key that this is a bang?
>> So again, here I [snorts] think the
mental mindset you should be in is that
we are being extremely methodical. So we
have an optimal control problem and we
follow the recipe. So the recipe entails
defining the Hamiltonian and then
enforcing the optimality conditions. The
way we mechanically go through the
optimality conditions is by starting
from the third one which is the in this
case finding use that globally minimize
the Hamiltonian which leads us to this.
If we were to continue we would then
take this and substitute it in the
differential equations.
we would then solve those differential
equations and get the kind of the full
thing. Uh here we're kind of again
stopping before the solution of the
differential equations that is only we
only get the global minimum of the
Hamiltonian. And this already gives us
the profile of our control signal,
right? Which in this case is is bang
bang because we already know that we
will basically be at the maximum control
uh on the on the boundaries of our
control at all times essentially.
kind of removing the singular arc
discussion. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. And so um essentially we showed
what we uh what what to do when the when
panspose p is uh different from zero. It
is not obvious what we do in the equal
to zero case. Um and we discuss this we
refer to these situations are singular
conditions or singular arcs
and I do if if you're interested in
learning more uh kind of the textbook
from Kirk we were referring to last week
is indeed a good reference for this
because it has some some discussions.
Okay. So now we move to towards a second
kind of archetype uh optimal control
problem uh which is minimum fuel. So in
this case the we have the same boundary
uh uh kind of bounds on the controls. We
have the exact same control alpha in
system but now we are uh changing the
cost whereby we start from an arbitary x
of0. We want to reach the origin in a
fixed time. So now time is fixed. It's
not a variable we're optimizing over.
And we want to reach the origin by
minimizing kind of the absolute value of
the control. And these types of problems
where we're minimizing absolute values
of the controls are usually referred to
as um minimum uh fuel problems.
Okay. So
again let's uh follow the usual uh the
usual procedure right. So we define the
Hamiltonian
which in this case G for us is the sum
from 1 to M of CI times the absolute
value of UI
plus P transpose A
plus the sum that goes from 1 to M of P
transpose BI UI. Here I skipped kind of
a couple steps but this is exactly
because the steps are exactly the same
as the ones we did before. So we express
B as uh in form in terms of the columns
and then that product essentially
becomes the linear combination of of the
columns of B.
Is it clear how we got to how we define
the Hamiltonian here?
Okay. So now we want to enforce our um
optimality condition such that the u has
to be a minimizer of the hamiltonian.
And again in this case the only terms
that depend on u are the first and the
third.
[snorts]
And so this boils down to
taking the minimum over u of the sum
that goes from 1 to m of ci time the
absolute value of ui plus p transpose b
i ui
right now again the u's are the
dimensions of u are independent and so
we can do exactly the same trick that
that minimizing The summation is equal
and equivalent to minimizing the
individual summation term for all i's
from 1 to m.
And so this means that it's equal to
minimizing over uis of ci time the
absolute value of ui plus p transpose bi
ui. And this is for all eyes uh from
one to n.
[snorts]
Okay.
So now let's
write this term slightly more uh nicely.
So
this is equal to ci plus p transpose
uh bi * ui if
ui is greater or equal than zero
and it is equal to negative ci
bi ui
if ui is less regal than zero.
Okay. And so we want to minimize this uh
object and again we have to go in a kind
of case by case uh analysis.
So
if P transpose BI is
greater than CI,
what happens is that this term is uh
positive.
And so
what U would I pick here if I want to
minimize this term?
Sorry, I I think you entered a zero.
Yes, which is which is correct. Did I
hear you something else or no? So indeed
it is zero. Um and so indeed so the in
the case where P transpose BI is greater
than equal to Z then uh greater than CI
um this is greater than zero which means
that in this case I would pick UI equals
to zero
um if we're still in that case then this
other condition would also be uh
positive right so this term here is also
positive and so here the UI that I would
pick would be MIUS
right And so in between these two cases
then for kind of this case here
UI star would be equal to mi minus.
Right?
Now we do another case that is the case
where prpose bi is between uh zero and
ci.
If this is the case, this is still
positive.
So here I would also pick uh UI equals
Z.
If
B transpose BI is between zero and CI,
this term here is negative.
And so UI the UI that I would have to
pick would also be zero to minimize,
right? And so essentially in this case,
U*
I is equal to zero.
Right
now just by mirroring I you know we
would go through the other two remaining
cases uh which essentially are that um
panspose bi are between
uh negative ci N0
and the fact that prpose pi
is um smaller than negative ci right so
these would be the other two cases
and here we would get that ui star is
equal z
and that ui star is equal mi plus this
is just by mirroring Right.
And so again kind of we we reached a
point where we have expressed u as a
from the third of our boundary from our
necessary optimality conditions. Uh
and we see that we are basic again we
are assuming we're not in the singular
arc conditions. So we are ignoring the
equal cases of these uh examples here.
But we have again pinpointed the
structure of our control profile. Right?
And
this is the one that you can see here on
the slide where UI depending on the
value of prposebi
is essentially either at its minimum
value or zero or at its maximum value.
And this is known as bang offbang
control. And if you think about what
we're doing here, u it is quite
intuitive again, right? Because this
essentially describes control profiles
where I want to get as quickly as
possible into a state where I'm
essentially coasting through my dynamics
uh where I can do nothing essentially
and then maybe only at the end do
another impulsive control
and this aligns with the objective of
minimizing fuel.
any any questions on on this example? I
think here it's kind of easy to kind of
get lost in the you know technicalities
of solving this minimization but I hope
that at a high level what we're doing is
starting to become clear because it
we're essentially repeating ourselves
over and over where we're enforcing our
optimality conditions by defining the
Hamiltonian optimizing the Hamiltonian
with respect to U. This gives us a
control profile which in order to kind
of solve the problem fully, we would
have to then do the appropriate
substitution and solve the differential
equations. Um, but this already gives us
a way to analyze the structure of our
control profile. Uh, yes.
>> Um, yeah, sorry. So when you were doing
the CI plus BTBI, that is just you
getting that derivative and saying like
that just gave you a derivative based on
like whatever the absolute value is and
then you were looking at the different
options of PTPI greater than CI. I'm a
little bit confused how then you got
that with a minimum based on PTI being
greater than CI because if PTI is
greater than that's just a positive
value. So we need some UI is just zero
>> and then so why is it now that the
>> you're talking about this case here.
>> Um so here remember that our function
we're optimizing is this one here right?
So it's a function where we have an
absolute value.
>> Yes.
>> And so it's we we kind of rewrote it
according to these two cases.
>> Yes. Now we are doing the case where P
transpose VI is greater than CI and we
want to find the minimum across both of
these values. Right? So if PRPOSE VI is
greater than CI, this is positive. And
in the case where UI has to be greater
than zero, the minimum would be UI
equals Z. In this other case, this is
positive. UI has to be less than zero.
And so the minimum would be MIUS. The
minimum between the two of them is when
UI is MIUS.
>> And will this have three singular works
where um obviously still the zero case
but also when it's equal to TI and
negative PI.
>> Yes, indeed. Here we are assuming that
our optimal control does not fall into
these conditions.
>> Yeah.
Conceptually, I'm wondering in the bang
off bang control sequence, is there
something in those terms that also
weighs um total time or is it purely
just minimizing fuel?
>> Uh this is if you look at the trajectory
that we were doing, do we didn't have an
explicit minimization over time, but
time was fixed.
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So the third case of the minimum
energy problem uh I would uh just go
through this quite quickly because it's
exactly the same case as the one that we
did on our kind of parabola and the
negative P2 that we did just after the
definition of the PMP. So I would go
through this quite quickly. Uh again
here the cases that we're minimizing a
squared uh cost functional. Um
and we would be doing the exact same
steps where we define the Hamiltonian.
Uh this Hamiltonian because of the we we
are assuming that r is positive definite
and diagonal. And so because of this
everything nicely decouples and so we
get the same situation where minimizing
these summation terms is equal to
minimizing an individual term of this
summation.
And so but since this is quadratic we
set the derivative of this equal to zero
and we will get this optimal control
which is exactly the analog of the
negative P2. So this is this is why I'm
kind of coasting through this because
this is exactly the same. Um and so we
would get our saturating control which
is the case we were looking at at the
beginning. Right? So we had our control
saturating when it's out of bounds
linear and then saturating again.
>> Yes.
>> Why is that?
>> I mean R if you think about it it's a
term we pick because we are defining the
cost that we want to optimize. And so
usually it's good to express diagonal
cost matrices because it makes things
easier.
But we could also pick an R that is not
diagonal. Yeah.
Okay. So
I want to so I have only 10 minutes
left. So I'll skip over this and finish
it next time. But I want to give you a
hint on computational methods and show
you how to solve these problems in
practice. And so basically until now
what we did is that we used our
optimality conditions to derive uh our
systems of differential equations and
our minimization over u equ.
And then we always kind of stopped at
the either we solved them analytically
as we did last week or here we stopped
at expressing u as a function of x and
ps and then you know we kind of said
that here we would substitute these back
in our differential equations and we
would solve them through numerical
solvers and at a high level numerical
techniques to solve uh twooint boundary
value problems kind of divide themselves
between indirect shooting methods uh and
uh collocation methods. Now we won't go
into the details of how these models uh
these techniques solve two boundary to
boundary uh two point boundary value
problems. But at a high level you should
see a shooting method as uh basically a
method that approximates a twopoint
boundary value problem as an initial
value problem where I take a guess of
what the initial value is. I kind of
propagate my system forward. I see my
error with respect to the final
condition. I will get a residual and
then I update my guesses uh kind of
iteratively.
Indirect collocation methods on the
other hand approximate uh the system
dynamics through uh basis functions for
example polomials and they enforce the
dynamics and the boundary conditions at
some specific points which are called
collocation points. And so these are
again not don't read too much into this
but this is just if you want to open the
box of how these numerical solvers
typically operate. They're either
implementing a shooting method or a
collocation method.
And we will be looking at our example
that it also came up earlier today uh
where we essentially optimizing the
particle on a line and we saw we solved
this analytically where we basically
derived the uh value of of TF.
But before getting there, I wanted to
just briefly introduce kind of in an
abstract example uh how these numerical
solvers uh look like and specifically
we'll be using the solve uh BVP uh
method of uh in in in Scypi um where
kind of at a high level the solv
essentially takes in a fun argument
which represents the right hand side of
our dynamics.
uh BC which represents the boundary
conditions expressed as the residuals of
the boundary conditions. So it has to be
something equal to zero. Um T which is
like a mesh of time meaning we are
discretizing time uh according to some
discrete uh bins and so this will be
just a sequence of uh discretization
time steps in uh which is just a series
of increasing numbers.
Z will be our aggregated um variable.
Essentially here we will have all our
states and constates uh kind of stacked
together
and and so kind of to see this in
practice let's look at a simple example
uh like the one here on the slide.
So um again kind of the as I said kind
of what these solvers usually take is
this solve BVP where we need to define
first of all the functions so our
differential equations and in the
example that we're looking at
we have um this system where we have Z1
dot equals Z2 and Z2 dot equals negative
absolute value of Z1.
And so here we're just basically
stacking those um those dynamics. So we
have remember that in Python counting
starts from uh zero. So we basically
have that Z1 dot is equal to Z2. So here
we're just saying Z2. And then we have
Z2 dot equals negative absolute value of
Z1. And so we have negative absolute
value of Z1.
Now we need to enforce our boundary uh
conditions
which are that Z1 at time 0 is equal to
zero and Z1 at time 4 is equal to -2.
And so [snorts] what we have here so uh
ZA is intended for the boundary
conditions at the initial time. And so
we have z a 0 equal to zero which is
essentially this term over here. And
then we have uh z4
+ 2 equals z because we have to express
them in the kind of residual form
which is what we have here.
Now we construct the t mesh uh which
essentially is again just a number which
informs what is the our discretization
of time in this case from zero to four
and we assume we have five uh bins
between 0 and four and z guess is just
um an initial guess of uh of our
variables at those at those times.
So what happens if we just run this is
that basically we we get that the
differential equations are solved. So
this is the plot of Z1 and Z2 over time.
So first of all it goes from 0 to 4 and
note that Z1 starts at zero
which was our boundary condition here
and it ends at -2
which was our final time boundary
condition.
And then note that um so Z2 is defined
as the
uh time derivative of of Z1. And so when
Z2 is is positive, Z1 grows.
When Z2 is negative, Z1 also decreases.
Right? So this is just like a visual
inspection that we did indeed solve
these differential equations.
[clears throat]
Okay. Um,
yeah. I'm I think I'll take some
questions now and then I'll wrap this up
next time. Yes.
dot =1
and then back out should be time
left.
So do you do you do you
>> in this case Z2 has to basically is
something that always decreases right
because the time derivative of Z2 is
negative an absolute value and so if you
also inspect this visually this is what
is happening but if you're talking about
other specific constraints on Z2 in this
case we we don't have any
>> so it can start and end
>> all right uh so see you on on Wednesday
we'll we'll be wrapping this
computational methods and then we'll
introduce direct methods. Thank you.